police in Northern Ireland were on high
alert on greg's at night this was a
security operation in OMA but it's now
emerged they were also sweeping belfast
port they didn't locate a bomb there but
later find a device on a lorry parked 25
miles away and believe it had been
destined for a Scotland bind Ferry it's
a viable device and that means it could
have caused death and very serious
injury and harm to members of the public
and those that have planted this device
with their intention of it exploding
were reckless or indeed determined to
cause that level of harm brexit ears
were celebrating in Parliament Square
when police in Belfast received a
warning that a bomb would explode on a
ferry as the UK left the EU unionists
say this incident should be treated the
same as any threat to a cross-channel
ferry and the First Minister was swift
to condemn those behind it this is very
concerning an incredibly reckless it has
to be said given that this lorry was
going to travel up army and motorway go
to army and port and possibly be on a
ferry goodness knows when that could
have exploded and could have caused
untold damage and loss of life it's just
over a year since dissident republicans
the so-called new IRA detonated a bomb
in a car outside Londonderry courthouse
three months later during rioting and
dairy's Cregan estate a gunman opened
fire on police lines murdering the
journalist Lera McKee dissident
republicans still pursuing Irish unity
by violent means have limited capability
and limited support but any threat to
onboard ferry traffic illustrates that
they don't need either of those things
to still pose what's deemed a severe
terrorist threat police say this device
could have exploded anywhere on the road
are at the docks and are appealing for
the public's help in tracking down the
would-be bombers David Blevins Sky News
Belfast